the spread is grave exceeding 7 000
confirmed cases today medical response
capacity is being rapidly exhausted
on wednesday south korea recorded more
new coronavirus infections than on any
single day in the pandemic
the health care system has been pushed
to its limit just as in many parts of
the world
exhausted staff too few beds equipment
shortages
what can be done to strengthen
healthcare systems and how best to
prepare for the next wave
[Music]
i'm ben fazel and welcome well the big
question is whether the damage to health
care systems is permanent because if you
do get sick at some stage maybe not now
but later in life who's going to look
after you
nurses and doctors worked to the limit
right now many are leaving their
profession and who can blame them
especially with the vaccine around that
not everyone wants to take
yulia butcher has been a nurse here for
seven years
she works at the f2 intensive care unit
at berlin's ukb trauma center
instead of treating accident victims her
station is filled exclusively with covet
19 patients
and each time she puts on a protective
suit gloves and so on
the works
treating coronavirus patients is
especially challenging and stressful
both physically and mentally
i have to be proactive with the patient
and sometimes i also say
i don't know if we'll see each other
again
these are things that you take home with
you you can't just work eight hours and
then go home and shut off
now during the coronavirus pandemic
you're permanently confronted with it
also privately and you take some of it
home with you
frustration at the unit is rising among
both nurses and doctors
almost none of the severely ill patients
have been vaccinated
we're seeing that 20 of our intensive
care capacity is occupied by patients
who for the most part wouldn't be here
if they had been vaccinated
it's frustrating
about 5 000 covet 19 patients are being
treated in germany's intensive care
units right now
that means about every fifth icu bed is
occupied by a coronavirus patient and as
a result planned operations must be
postponed
senior physician hans joachim janssen is
convinced that without a vaccine mandate
as the government is currently
discussing the problem cannot be tackled
there is simply a difference between
having a vaccination rate of about 70
percent or one of more than 85 percent
it has a massive effect on infection
activity and getting to that point is
very difficult we won't make it
otherwise this winter it would affect us
again next summer and autumn that's why
i'm for a vaccine mandate
patient receives these medications and
more every day
those who don't want to get vaccinated
say these medical professionals should
keep that reality in mind
and let's pick up on that last point
with martin mckee director of research
policy at the european observatory on
health systems and policies he joins us
from london
what are the consequences of this
pandemic of the unvaccinated on health
care systems
well the consequences are really for
three groups of people obviously those
people who are infected with covet
themselves not just that they will get
ill and they risk dying but also
whenever hospitals are overwhelmed then
the ability to provide care for them is
compromised the second group are for the
people who have other conditions cancer
for example or are awaiting transplants
and they cannot get the intensive care
that they will need so their operations
are being postponed and in some cases
that could be fatal it could mean losing
an organ that they would otherwise
receive and the third group that you've
just heard from are the staff who are
not just suffering from burnout but also
from a new phenomenon that we've more
traditionally associated with the armed
forces that we call moral injury and
that's the sense we've just heard it
described there of where p health
workers want to provide the best quality
care but they simply cannot because of
the overwhelming workload that they face
and that has major implications for
their mental well-being
what's the solution for that for that
last point that you make
well within europe we see enormous
differences in capacity in hospitals
germany is very fortunate in this it has
several times more intensive care unit
beds than for example the united kingdom
but generally what we have seen is that
countries that have done better are the
ones that they can ex that can expand
into existing capacity now that's not
just having beds and hospitals the
crucial
limiting factor is the number of staff a
number of countries like the united
kingdom set up these uh hospitals field
hospitals and conference centers but
we're not able to use them because they
didn't have the staff but the other
crucial area is the issue is the ability
to redeploy staff and to bring in other
people to help with the work what we
call task shifting and where that's been
able to be done that's been able to help
quite a lot
we keep hearing about better pay for
doctors and nurses which would be great
but it's not going to solve everything
is it by
what you're saying
well we need to be careful with that
argument because in many countries we
don't pay health workers enough and they
recognize that they're undervalued now
if we look to the eastern part of the
european union we see that often you
have informal payments which compensates
to some extent but that's not the way we
want to go forward but we also i think
really need to look at working
conditions it's the way in which we
value staff in healthcare facilities
whether they can get hot meals in the
middle of the night for example if they
have somewhere to rest so all of those
things about making sure that people do
actually feel valued and they have some
support when they need it
there is quite a lot that has been
learned from that i sit on the european
commission's expert panel on investing
in health and we've just published a
report which looks at the evidence on
all of the things that can be done to
support health workers in these
circumstances so how much more does need
to be invested in health
well some countries are have health
systems that are already quite well
resourced germany france for example
others clearly need to spend quite a bit
more but it's not just how much money
you do need to have in many countries
more money than particularly with an
aging population a aging population with
complex
chronic diseases multiple chronic
diseases and that's going to put upward
pressure on health systems everywhere
but it is very much about how you spend
it as well and we do need to look at the
models of care that we have after the
pandemic we need to look much more at
team working i know that there are
debates in germany about healthcare
reform going forward that's true in many
countries and how do we deal with the
challenges of this changing population
when we will have fewer young people and
that means fewer health workers but more
older people with the multiple
conditions
martin from what you're saying it all
sounds like permanent damage to
healthcare systems
in many countries it's going to take a
very long time to recover from all of
this because we have as you've heard had
a lot quite a few staff who are saying
do i really want to be doing this for
the rest of my life they're getting
perhaps to their 50s and they're feeling
that they're completely exhausted and
they're leaving and in many countries in
europe the healthcare workforce has
itself been aging so we have a major
challenge there but yes i think we're
going to have to start looking at ways
of doing things and in particular the
way in which we share out the different
roles between different types of health
workers doctors nurses pharmacists
therapists and others but also between
health workers and patients and their
carers and also look at increasing use
of technology because of course now many
people people will have
almost a mini laboratory at home if
they've got a chronic disease they can
check their ecg they can check their
blood sugars all sorts of things
and so we're seeing the way in which
technology can help in all of that but
it all needs to be put together in a
comprehensive package there's no magic
solution here
you heard it from martin mckee the
european observatory on health systems
and policies thank you very much for
being on the show today
thank you
well here's a question on omicron now
from one of our viewers and here's derek
williams
will vaccines protect people against the
new omicron variant
we don't know yet but it's certainly
possible that the variant will be able
to evade immunity to some extent some
experts even think that it's likely
let's look for a minute at why
omicron has around 30 mutations that
could affect the structure of its spikes
those
those protein clusters dotting its
exterior that the virus uses to break
into cells which it has to do in order
to start replicating
the spikes are also
the home in target for the antibodies
created
when the immune system responds to a lot
of the vaccines that we've developed
if the spike therefore changes a lot or
so the theory then the vaccine-induced
antibodies that are built to recognize
the old version of the protein they
might not do that any longer now
antibodies are just one component of the
immune system there are others that
could help make up
for any lost ground and booster shots
could also help relativize any
vaccine resistance still
a lot of scientists are worried that
vaccine-based immunity
could prove weaker for omicron some
indicators from south africa back that
idea up for example um the speed at
which
the new variant is spreading there it's
moving pretty fast and infecting lots of
people
even though a significant fraction of
the population
should have some immunity due to either
vaccination or previous infection so
experts are saying
both breakthrough infections and
re-infections are probably occurring at
a faster rate
than with most previously seen variants
but
it's also not really possible at the
moment to make predictions about how
omicron might affect other countries for
example
those with older populations or
higher vaccination rates or lower
numbers of natural infections
at this point
the biggest hope that healthcare
officials everywhere have
is that vaccines will at least continue
to mostly protect recipients
from severe disease caused by omicron as
they do with other variants but
there isn't really enough data yet
to call that more than a hope
you